welcome back to 8701
so we continue our discussion our
development of qed
is a discussion of the photon we have
already seen how we can describe
electrons and positrons anti-electrons
and now it's time to actually look at
the quantum of electromagnetism of
electromagnetic
fields a few general remarks first
quantum electrodynamic is a quantum
field theory
the quantum field theory of electro
dynamic processes describing how light
interactions matter
specifically all processes where
a photon is used
as an exchange particle involving
electrically charged particles
can be described by qed the photon
itself is the
limit is an elementary particle and it's
the quantum of the electromagnetic field
good the real power in qed lies in the
fact that we
can describe it as a perturbation theory
we'll see that we can
write down finding diagrams calculate
them and use those calculations for
to describe processes we can observe in
experiments
and since we can do this with a very
high precision uh we can use
qud in order to make forecasts in order
to understand in order to understand the
inner dynamics of processes we can
measure
feinman called qd our pride and joy
and it's in the in the really unmatched
precision of the theory
where the pride and joy lies
but stepping back one step let's start
with classical electron dynamics and
let's start from
maxwell equations and i'm going to use
this and just
to make a few points and remarks um
this is really not in the direct path of
our development but it
connects the dots to something you have
already studied
meaning classical electrodynamics so you
you know you all have seen maxwell
equations they can be expressed in
integral or differential form and you
can
write this even more compact then then
it's given here
so you see gauss's law where you see
that
electric charges generate electric
fields
you can see that you can produce
currents
by time changing electric fields or by
changing especially changing magnetic
fields
gauss's law for magnetic fields
saying that there is no magnetic charge
no magnetic monopole
at least as far as we know we haven't
observed those
and then there's faraday's law as well
you can express the magnetic field and
the electric field through
potentials and vector potentials
um and if you go one step further you
see this very nice form
using four vectors for the potential and
the vector potential and
the charge and the the current so what
we're
really doing here right now is we're
just rewriting the very same equations
and so when we use this um
dalai bashin operator um
the form of this equation looks like
this
you can already see this form is very
similar to the
to the um uh clan gordon equation we
just looked at
so let's you know go down this path a
little bit more
so this here is yet another form to
write
the maxwell equations um
where f is our field strength tensor
and the field strength has all the
physics involved you see that you know
you're describing the electromagnetic
field in its components
and then the simplification of the
maxwell equations
are sitting here so we have in a mixed
equation in this form we have the
maxwell equation in this form here
so there's one interesting thing when we
use
potential in order to describe electric
electromagnetic
processes or
[Music]
properties is that we can actually
choose
the specifics of the gauge there's a
degree of freedom
which we can choose which doesn't have
any impact on the physics and the
reality of the physics
right and you can see this here if you
do this if you use a choice at this
component here zero
um this is called the column gauge
we basically simplify again our maxwell
equations to this point here
great so um
there's a number of things to be said so
what we're basically doing here if we
fix
a gauge so if we fix our potential we
tie um the choice of the potential
to the frame to the inertial frame we're
using here and you could say
ah that's not nice that doesn't seem
lauren's in variant
it is actually okay to do this the issue
with that is that you
you tie you know if you go from one
frame and the other
you have to actually change the the
gauge
as you go along with changing the
reference frame
but there's nothing bad it's just a
little bit awkward
all right then moving back so we have
this equation now
and this equation obviously simplifies
if there is no current or no charged
around for three photons
um to this one and for this you can find
the solution it's again the free wave so
this was the goal of this lecture
finding the free weight
so you could have probably written this
down before any of the discussion but i
just want to make the connection
so now this in qed this a new
becomes our back function for the photon
again we have to you know this is
as a result of the of the gauge we we
made so we made a specific choice in our
reference frame
and then we can we can describe the full
term with our wave function here
there's this epsilon here epsilon is our
polarization vector
and a is a normalization factor we
always always have to
normalize our wave functions to you know
specific
um sets of units all right that's good
um we can now analyze this we find that
those conditions
are fulfilled here uh
basically saying that you know photon
behaves like a photon the energy of the
photon is equal to
the momentum times c um that's great
but it's also not a surprise because the
form of this equation here
is exactly that of the clangordin
equation with small for masses particles
and the clang gordon equation we got
from this very same relation so it's not
surprised that this works out
all right one more word on the
polarization vector
um so the choice we just made
i'm rewriting the choice here this is
our coulomb gauge um
requires that the zeroth component of
our polarization vector is
zero and that the polarization vector is
orthogonal
to the momentum vector so in principle
you have the three vector the three
vector is
perpendicular to the direction of motion
and that allows us
to find two polarization states which
are independent of each other
so different to our electrons before now
we don't have
four states you only have two states as
independent solutions
for a given for a given momentum
all right so with this now we have
electrons we can describe those we can
describe photons
the next step now is to look at the
feynman rules which allows us to
describe the interaction between those
two